good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock very welcome to join us on the
breakfast show on Sky News a development
overnight in the hump for a missing
Aristocrat we're live on the scene of a
massive police search in Brighton plus
can the pm get his brexit deal over the
line with the dup the foreign secretary
James cleverley on the program very
shortly and the shadow Northern Ireland
secretary Peter Carlin the eight o'clock
hour it's Tuesday the 28th of February
please search in Brighton as an
aristocrat is arrested with her partner
but a newborn baby is still missing
the couple were reported missing after
their car broke down near Bolton last
month
if it's make or break for the Windsor
framework anywhere it's here in Northern
Ireland the restoration of power sharing
government at last hangs on its success
I'm on a picket line in Leeds as
teachers across the north of England
strike overpay the education secretary
says it is unacceptable
I'm in Beijing where Belarus president
Anne Putin Ally Alexander lukashenko is
due for estate visit it comes as
concerns increase that China may start
selling arms to Russia
how football fans in Turkey chose to
give gifts to children affected by the
earthquake life throwing teddy bears
onto the pitch
the Southern Lights a treat for
stargazers down south as the northern
lights but on a show for a second night
remembering Betty tributes to the Tila
girl turned top politician will be
joined by the current speakers to
Lindsay Hoyle at half past eight
foreign
[Music]
50 years of Pride with some of the
biggest names in Showbiz telling us what
the anniversary means to them
[Music]
good morning breaking news from
overnight and a development in the hunt
for a missing Aristocrat the couple
sparked a nationwide police Hunter after
they went missing with their newborn
baby they've now been found and arrested
but police say the baby is missing
and a search is underway Saba has got
more for us now in Brighton what on
Earth's going on there good morning
good morning KY as you say Constance
Martin and Mark Gordon uh have been
spotted in Brighton not too far from
where we are by a member of the public
just last night down the road from here
before 9 30 p.m they were subsequently
arrested and are in police custody but
here's the main thing their newborn
child who was with them and had been
spotted with them is now missing and a
major police operation to find their
child as currently underway as I'm sure
you can see behind me now originally
this was a missing person's operation
for the family of three who were who
have been cited up and down the country
first in Liverpool in Essex and South
London and also in East Sussex now the
police are saying that if members of the
public have any information that they
should urgently come forward because
they have serious concerns for the
child's welfare who they believe
was born just a month ago and they're
urging people to phone 999 as soon as
they can if they have information yeah
this baby um about a month old as you
said
um and it's not with the parents they've
been traveling up and down the country
the police must be desperately worried
about what's happened
absolutely they are and um they at the
moment there's not a huge amount of
information they can say but from uh
speaking with them earlier they did say
that extensive searches are going on in
the area from where the couple were
spotted last night just before 9 30 p.m
and as soon as we have any further
updates we'll let you know
okay thank you
if you're not the news prime minister is
expected to travel to Northern Ireland
today after securing a deal that he says
will be a turning point for the region
you'll be hoping to get the back backing
of the dup who've said there are still
some issues of concern here's what's
been agreed first a twin Lane system for
Customs the Green Lane will allow
trusted traders to send goods from
Britain into Northern Ireland without
checks meanwhile Goods destined for
Ireland and the EU single Market will go
through the red lane
v80 rates and state aid policy will be
set by Westminster rather than by
Brussels there'll also be a storm or
break allowing Northern Ireland's
assembly to prevent EU laws applying but
the European court of justice will keep
the final say on single Market issues a
significant sticking point for Tory Euro
Skeptics and the dep
in Broad terms it is clear that
significant progress has been secured
across a number of areas whilst also
recognizing that there remain key issues
of concern
where necessary We Stand ready to engage
with the government
in order to seek further clarification
reworking or change as required
senior toybert Venture David Davis who
quitters brexit secretary over Theresa
May's negotiation strategy had this
message for brexiteers in his party
I'd say to them read this carefully go
through it compare it with the other
things that you've already voted for
remember most of these members of my
party have voted for borises a deal this
is much better than boris's deal but
from the sovereignty point of view from
a trade point of view from a democracy
point of view it's better
well our correspondence David Blevins
and Adam Parsons are at Stormont and
also in Brussels respectively this
morning David to you first of all
is this still going to get over the line
well the dup K have not said yes but
notably nor have they reverted to their
traditional default position of saying
no instead we've got this mixed message
thing going on where the party leader
Sir Jeffrey Donaldson is rather
conciliatory suggesting there's been
progress commending the Prime Minister
for his efforts and committing to study
the document line by line every detail
of it on the other hand one of his MPS
Ian Paisley has already said it doesn't
cut the mustard they're still concerned
about the sovereignty question about who
ultimately has the last say on EU law in
Northern Ireland the question is can
that be mitigated enough to see this
place the devolved government of
Northern Ireland up and running again
before the 25th anniversary of the Good
Friday agreement Michelle O'Neill who's
been first Minister and waiting for more
than a year is urging the unionists to
form a government with her so that they
fill the political vacuum and send a
very clear message to those who even
just last week were illustrating that
the piece is very fragile okay it was
quite a loving yesterday wasn't it Adam
yeah and I think that was indicative of
a far improved relationship between the
European Union and the UK I've spoken to
a number of people who were operating
behind the scenes on this deal and all
of them without exception have said that
that was fundamental to getting the deal
done now I don't think we should read
into that Ursula Wonderland and British
sunak have suddenly become great friends
what we're talking about is a good
professional relationship in contrast to
an absolutely terrible relationship
previously last night I spoke to one of
the those who was involved in the
negotiations and said that when Boris
Johnson was talking nobody was listening
and that nobody wanted to talk uh to
Lord Frost in the previous round of
negotiations that has all changed now
the EU thinks that they have made
significant concessions what they want
is a deal to get this across the line a
deal may not be perfect they say but a
deal is better than no deal
putting all of that to the foreign
secretary who we heard from the Prime
Minister yesterday said was integral to
this deal he's coming up in just a few
minutes time half past seven I'm going
to be speaking to uh Kevin Courtney of
the National Education Union as teachers
begin three days of strike action
Porsche 8 speaking to the former head of
the British army Lord done it as the war
rages in Ukraine and issues with
airspace airspace rather overhauled over
and the shadowed Northern Ireland
secretary Peter Carl will give us
Labor's take on yesterday's major deal
that's at just after eight
thousands of teachers are beginning a
three-day strike this morning across
Northern England in a dispute overpay
the education secretary Jillian Keegan
says it's Unforgivable
it was a serious offer to pause strikes
get around the table and to come in and
to talk about all of the issues that
were part of the dispute that was a
serious offer the nurses have taken up
that offer they've been in discussions
ever since then the teaching Union has
not and that's very disappointing and
particularly the impact it's going to
have on children
well let's get more on this should we
standing by our north of England
correspondent shingy mariki is on a
picket line in Leeds for three days of
strike starting in the north where you
washing you good morning
good morning Kay that's right those
three days of strike action have all
involved hundreds of thousands of
teachers according to the Neu the
largest teaching Union overpay just like
across the board in so many other
sectors they're asking for a pay
increase above inflation the picket line
here at this school in Leeds are started
you can hear them chanting you can hear
them voicing their discontent with the
government and I have one of those
teachers with me Vicky who's taught here
for 30 years just tell us why you're out
here today and why this matters so much
to you I think this matters so much
because it's about the future of our
society that um I've been teaching here
for 30 years and we have had a cut in
funding for the past 12 years we've been
papering over the cracks but now as you
can see we're not able to do that
anymore and we need to be providing for
the future of our country and we need to
be at the top of the government's agenda
and that's why we're here and what do
you think about the government's
position they've laid out which is
essentially they want you to stop your
strike action then they'll come to the
table thoughts on that
um I I feel that there needs to be some
middle ground that they absolutely need
to come to the table and they need to to
um the majority of people here it's not
about how much money they're gonna
increase our pay it needs to be funded
because if it's not funded our head
teachers cannot provide the support for
the children they have to find the money
elsewhere and that is what concerns us
as a profession
thank you very much Vicky so there you
have it they think it's about the future
of our young people and that's what
matters to them if they don't reach some
sort of deal with the government and
break this impasse then there's the
potential for more strike action in
March okay
thank you and
other top stories for you know here on
the breakfast show a fertility regulator
is calling for children born via sperm
or egg donation to be given the right to
learn about their birth parents before
the age of 18. the human fertilization
and embryology Authority has begun a
consultation that will run for six weeks
there's a warning that tax hikes or
spending cuts would be needed for the
government to end strike action over
public sector pay disputes The Institute
for fiscal studies says the government
is not able to raise public sector pay
to match inflation despite the UK being
on course to borrow 30 billion pounds
less than forecast
long waits for a e treatment contributed
to more than 23 000 excess deaths last
year data from the Royal College of
emergency medicine suggests weights of
more than 12 hours in a e created
catastrophic consequences for safety
NHS England disagrees spokesperson told
us the cause of excess deaths is down to
a number of different factors and so
attributing deaths to one exact thing as
the figures quoted by the rcem attempt
to do is very unlikely to give a full or
certain picture
a rapist who self-identified as female
during criminal proceedings will be
sentenced at Edinburgh high court today
Isla Bryson was removed from a female
prison after being found guilty of
raping two women between 2016 and 2019
first Minister Nicholas sturgeon
suggested the rapist was almost
certainly faking being transgender
police in Ecuador seized nearly nine
tons of cocaine hidden it and a
container of bananas Bound for Belgium
the police say the shipment would have
been worth more than 270 million pounds
had it reached its destination
I say what you like about football fans
sometimes they've got huge Hearts there
we go match between two top-flight
Turkish football teams was paused as
fans threw teddies and other fluffy toys
onto the pitch for the children caught
up in the earthquakes that hit turkey
and Syria the match was suspended for
four minutes and 17 seconds a reference
to the time the first earthquake struck
three weeks ago warm clothing also
thrown onto the pitch for those who were
trying to survive under canvas in
Sub-Zero temperatures
Russian President Alexander lukashenko a
close Ally of Vladimir Putin is visiting
Beijing prompting further concerns that
China may consider providing military
aid to Russia let's get more on this
should we Helena standing by for us this
morning Helen on what are they up to
well we understand that President
lukashenko will be arriving in Beijing
today he's staying until Thursday and we
understand that as part of this state
visit he will also be meeting President
Xi Jinping himself now look both sides
both the Bella Russians and the Chinese
are billing this as a a reasonably
ordinary visit between two leaders two
allies that say they're going to talk
about things from the economy to
humanitarian Aid a trade and a number of
other things but of course the context
for this and the reason it matters so
much is the conflict in Ukraine and
particularly the timing just that one
year on last week since the conflict
broke out now Belarus and Alexander
lukashenko the president of Belarus is a
staunch Putin Ally he's been one of
Putin's strongest supporters during this
conflict actually part of the invasion
was actually launched via belarussian
territory at the Chinese on the other
hand have been extremely careful for the
year of this conflict to not be seen to
be taking side they have never never
overtly condemned or condoned the war
but quietly as time has gone on they
have provided financial assistance to
the Russians they have certainly
provided diplomatic cover and the West
is nervous because there have been
perhaps increasing signals in recent
months and weeks that China might might
be moving slightly closer to the
Russians over this not least warnings
from the Americans that they are worried
and have intelligence that Russia might
be preparing to sell arms to the
Russians if that were to happen of
course that escalates things
significantly so in the eyes of the West
this state visit another worrying signal
the Chinese saying that it's just part
of their efforts they say to try and be
a broker of Peace within the conflict
okay thank you
um joining us now is the foreign
secretary James Cleveland lots to talk
about let's just touch on that should we
very briefly
um what are the Chinese and the better
Russians up to well look we will look
very very closely at what statements
come out from this meeting
um the the simple truth is this war is
unprovoked it was illegal it was
unjustified uh we have made it
absolutely clear that we're helping the
ukrainians defend themselves but also as
I said in New York at the United Nations
at the tail end of last week we are also
defending the UN Charter international
law territorial Integrity all these
things okay
um
the deal that was done in 2019
for brexit
did we already have it a deal then why
did we have to do another deal
so I think you the deal that was done
the oven ready deal yeah that was the
withdrawal agreement that was to enable
us to actually leave the European Union
which we did in
um in January of 2020.
um so what we have been doing what we've
been negotiating over the last few
months and what was resolved yesterday
between the Prime Minister and Ursula
Wonderland was the uh the details about
ensuring that Northern Ireland remains a
meaningful full part of the United
Kingdom whilst also of course having
privileged access to the European single
Market making sure that the institutions
of the Good Friday agreement
particularly the Stormont executive are
back up and running
and resolving these last residual issues
in terms of that relationship when you
say last residual issues I've got a
little list sausages and children meets
banned under the old protocol now it's
been fixed Parcels unnecessary
bureaucracy fixed online shopping extra
barriers now fixed I'm planting potatoes
band no fixed pets costly certificates
band fix the list goes on and on and on
lots of people would have thought that
had already been sorted out it quite
clearly had notched the leader of the
opposition is now saying that this is a
compromise
what you're offering why is he wrong
I mean the leader of the opposition
wouldn't understand I think how
negotiations work it seems because
well I mean if it's me you're on the
phone somebody well if he describes it
as a as a compromise uh I think uh What
uh what I've heard is uh Business
Leaders Community leaders
representatives of uh retail Community
um the uh bespokesperson from the guide
dogs Association a whole load of other
people really welcome what we've
achieved because what we've achieved is
something that a lot of people said we
could never achieve which is a
negotiated change to
um the the treaties that underpin the
the the the the cross I receive trade
and also the relationship with Northern
Ireland and Ireland we've got now a very
a really really good result it means
that Northern Ireland is in the same uh
tax
environments as the rest of the UK it
means the deal signed off it's not been
signed off yet well it means that it
means that
products from within the UK can flow as
freely from Birmingham to Belfast it's
not been signed off yet but the this is
this is a really really good this is a
really really good uh uh agreement which
as I say protects Northlands part of the
of the UK also gives them that
privileged access to the single market
and and I think really really
importantly gives the elected
representatives of the people of
Northern Ireland a genuine say in the
rules and regulations you need the dup
on side what's the boss going to say
when it goes to Northern Ireland this
morning well I think what he's going to
do is going to talk through the
practicalities of what's been agreed we
took the we we listen very very
carefully to the people the businesses
and the elected representatives in
Northern Ireland particularly the
unionist community and their
representatives who who really felt that
the protocol was was severing that that
that incredibly important link between
no Northern Ireland and the rest of the
United States that was because you're
old boss your big body said that there
wouldn't be a border down the Irish sea
and it might be a softer one now but
it's still there
so so when it comes to the movement of
goods within the UK
there will be no greater regulatory
burden than moving things from
Birmingham to Braintree still a border
no there isn't okay
I need to have a green and and red um
because the red lane is for stuff that
ultimately will be crossing a border
into the European Union into Ireland
into the European Union but within the
UK there is no border the regulatory
environment is exactly the same as if
it's moving anywhere else within the UK
products that weren't available in North
Island will be available meat products
sausages for example seed potatoes from
Scotland
yes so so so this this means that the
the uh um the nursery the the garden
center that I visited Northern Ireland
who could not get roses who could not
get Oak saplings who couldn't see
because of your old boss you could not
get seed potatoes they can now get all
of these things just as easily as if
they're in my constituency so the dup
don't agree with you then they don't
understand negotiations either like Pier
Starman they are going to quite
understandably want to look at the
detail of this what are they of course
of course they will want to look at the
detail of this but I really hope that
once they look at the detail of this
they will they will see that we have
taken back
well I'm not gonna I'm not gonna uh I'm
going to I'm going to give and I know
them respect them very very uh March and
they know
um I I know all the uh the MPS of the
dup and I've had a chance to meet their
leadership uh in Northern Ireland I
think they will know that I've been very
very focused on the concerns that they
have expressed on behalf of their
communities
that they will have real Authority when
it comes to the storm on break they will
have a genuine save the power to
discover a deal well what I really
really hope is they'll look at this and
they will understand they still have the
power to discover a deal well look
ultimately this is about making sure
that the people of Northern Ireland are
served properly that means getting the
storm do they still have the power to
Scupper a deal well if if if if they
don't re-enter
um uh the power sharing executive that
will be hugely disappointed I think that
will be that'll be that won't be good
news for the people in Northern Ireland
but I think this deal do they still have
the power to scuffer a deal ultimately
yes we want Stormont up and running that
is something and I'm not I'm I I what I
want to do and I know your question what
I want to do what I want to do is I want
to give the dup I want to give the
representatives the unionist community
the chance to read this I want I want
them I want them to how many times do I
have to ask you because I tell you
because I know what you want to do you
want to I want you to tell me the answer
well you and it's a yes or no you're not
trapping you I'm asking you is do they
still have the power to Scupper a deal
the dup or are they not as powerful as
they used to be well you see and that's
why I'm that's why I'm not going to be
drawn into this because because this is
not this is no because actually the real
giveaway was the subsequent question
about are they not as powerful as they
used to be the dup are passionate
representatives of their communities in
Northern Ireland they've raised
they number they raised a number of
concerns about the implementation of the
protocol we listen very very carefully
and we have systematically gone through
to resolve the issues to make sure that
the tax and Regulatory environments
I've just read them all out for people
so
you'll recognize
commission has moved a very very long
way from the start absolutely that
they've agreed things that we were told
uh with great confidence would never be
agreed
um
the king if I may just before I let you
go I know that you're a little bit cross
about talking about the king who asked
uh for the king to speak to host uh Mrs
Wonderland was it down in street or was
it Buckingham Palace well obviously we
arranged for Ursula vondeline to come to
the UK to conduct the final part of the
negotiation we we of course uh informed
the palace and ultimately with the
visiting of any senior uh uh
International Airport and he said yeah
okay whether it be whether it be
president zielinski or present uh uh
Wonderland from the EU so um but
ultimately decisions about the uh the
king's diary are rightly for the uh for
the palace eight minutes flies good to
talk to you as always thanks very much
indeed thanks a lot quick look at the
papers for you uh the New Deal between
the UK and the EU is the lead story for
many including the eye the male asks has
the Prime Minister actually achieved The
Impossible lots of people think so the
guardian hails a new chapter in
relations with the EU the times brexit
breakthrough says the times Telegraph
quotes the Prime Minister saying his
deal is a new way forward Metro says we
can finally put the oven on
see what they did there and stargazers
had another treat last night as the
Northern Lights gave another sparkling
display in the night skies how beautiful
I love the Northern Lights also known as
the Aurora Borealis the rare display
could be seen above the Skies of Chorley
wood in Hertfordshire caused by a
combination of different gases and the
effects of the Earth's magnetic field
that makes up the colors and wave
patterns as seen in the world as well
very very beautiful quick look at the
weather
warm memory memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
largely dry and settle but staying
chilly with overnight Frost where skies
are clearing
sponsored by Qatar Airways
looking at our climate dashboard for you
now I always look at the coal first less
than one percent of our Energy Mix is
coal at the moment not many Renewables
though a lot of gas we're using today as
you can see this is how much it is
hotter since 1880 and this is CO2
emissions in millions of tons in real
time now then it's more than 50 years
since a million people first took to the
Streets of London in support of Pride
and to celebrate photographer Thomas
Knights has taken 50 portraits of lgpd Q
Plus people there you go
great pictures the portraits will form
part of an exhibition launching today
and featuring some of the biggest names
in Showbiz plus they've spoken about
what the anniversary means to them
[Music]
amazing talking about that in more
detail later on in the program uh still
to come is it a monkey an elf or some
kind of ghostly Apparition what did
Mexico's president see in his garden
looks like an owl to me
[Music]
telling you before the break about the
Mexican president who's posted a picture
to his social media showing what looks
to be a mythical creature similar to an
elf the president appeared to be serious
when he posted the photo on Twitter
which has now been viewed millions of
times he described it as an Alex which
is a small mischievous creature similar
to elves that are supposed to live in
forests others have suggested it was a
monkey or an unwelcome intruder
I think it's probably a monkey it looks
like a monkey doesn't it
um no we're going to be telling you
about what the foreign secretary said
about the dup and whether they are still
relevant with the new uh Accord that we
heard about yesterday between the Prime
Minister and Ursula Von de Lyon what did
he have to say stay tuned find out
before that around 200 000 teachers in
England will today begin three days of
industrial action as their long-running
disputes overpay continues let's talk
about it in more detail joining us the
joint General Secretary of the National
Education Union Kevin Courtney hello to
Mr Courtney thanks for joining us on the
program this morning uh what impact will
this these three days of strikes have on
schools
well lots of schools will be affected
and many children will have to remain at
home and I want to say to UK we
sincerely regret the disruption to
children's education and to parents
working and home lives today but we
think we're taking action for a high
moral purpose to try and get the
government to invest in this generation
of children who are being ignored by
this government so there will be
disruption on the three days of actions
at its strike today in the North
tomorrow in the Midlands on Thursday in
the South and we regret that disruption
but we want government to invest in this
generation of children
impact on exam students so funny
well I mean it's the same the same point
being made we regret that disruption now
teachers will work really hard with
those exam classes they want their
children to do well in the exams that
are coming up but we make the point that
there are GCSE chemistry classes without
teachers who are qualified in chemistry
there are GCSE maths classes that are
being taught without teachers who are
qualified in maths and that is impacting
on those children exams preparation
every day and we're trying to get
government to invest in order to
overcome those problems
[Music]
okay so does that mean that exam
students will be impacted no
they certainly will I mean many schools
the exam classes will be in school but
there will be schools where they're out
there will be schools where those
children are out of school if they're
out of school I think they should be
doing uh exam preparation that's what
they could do this afternoon if they're
not coming on our demonstration but my
point to you okay is that their
education has been disrupted every day
by the fact that we haven't got enough
teachers in our schools in our qualified
teachers we don't have enough permanent
teachers there are temporary teachers
doing their best but children are being
disrupted every single day and that's
because the government has let teacher
Recruitment and Retention for the such
perilous levels there have been pay cuts
there have been pay Rises less than
inflation almost every year since this
government was elected in 2010 and they
are carrying on now the pay rise last
September was five percent when
inflation was 12 the pay rise they're
forecasting for this September is three
percent and from forecast of inflation
are 10 on RPA for this September even
though it's starting to fall or six
percent on CPI and those paid cuts are
leading to a situation where we don't
have enough teachers in our schools and
in addition when they make pay Rises
they often don't fund them properly so
that schools have to make cut stuff
under pay Rises and that's why our
members are taking a stand and they see
themselves and I agree with them taking
a stand for the children they teach they
are standing up for Education they are
standing up for their profession and
they are trying to make sure that this
government invests in this generation of
children the generation of children hits
so hard by covid we're trying to make
sure the government invests in that
generation of children
Mr Courtney um
for me if you would please reported that
your joint General Secretary Mr a very
important meeting with the education
security because she was enjoying the
Norwegian Fields
um is that right
we were fully represented at that
meeting I was at that meeting Mary had a
long booked uh cruise on a over
half-term holiday that she booked with a
friend many years a couple of years
before and we agreed she could go to
that because I would be at the meeting
with the Secretary of State what they
this is Mischief making by the
department for Education it is not a way
to will to build trust in the
negotiations because what they haven't
told you is that a minister Nick Gibb
was also not at that meeting because he
was on a half-term break why do they
tell you one part of that and not the
other part it's just Mischief making on
their part and it damages the prospect
of reaching an agreement because they
they destroy trust in the negotiation
process
because Nick Gibbs not asking teachers
to go on strike and your joints General
Secretary is probably
well we're not asking members to go on
strike our members have voted in
overwhelming numbers to go on strike
this government really doesn't like the
fact that working people are allowed to
take strike action but they are taking
strike action it's the most effective
strike action we've had I think since
the 1980s in terms of the number of
people involved in it the fact that 50
000 people have joined our Union fifty
thousand people have joined our Union
since we announced our ballot results on
January the 16th tells you that teachers
it's not us it's not me and Mary making
people go on strike teachers have had
enough they want the government to
invest in them invest in their
profession and invest in the education
of the children in our schools
okay
um it's going to
good as we said these strikes um going
on for I think three days I'm sure we'll
chat again or perhaps there will be a
deal before that I'm sure that so many
students and teachers live in hope that
that's the case but for now thank you
for joining us as always thank you
absolutely
thank you thanks uh let's return to that
big story this morning continued
scrutiny of the prime minister's New
Deal on Northern Ireland with the EU
Rishi sunak is heading to Northern
Ireland today and all eyes are on
whether the dup will be reassured with a
new deal earlier I asked the foreign
secretary eight times whether the dup
actually have the power to Scupper a
deal
well look ultimately this is about
making sure that the people of Northern
Ireland are served properly that means
getting the storm do they still have the
power to
power if if if if they don't re-enter
um uh the power sharing executive that
will be hugely disappointing I think
that'll be that'll be that won't be good
news for the people in Northern Ireland
but I think this deal do they still have
the power
deal ultimately yes we want Stormont up
and running that is something and I'm
not I'm I I what I want to do and I know
you've got a question for us what I want
to do what I want to do is I want to
give the dup I want to give the
representatives the unionist community
the chance to read this I want I want
them I want them to how many times do I
have to ask you because I tell you
because I know what you want to do you
want to I want you to tell me the answer
well and it's a yes or no you're not
trapping you I'm asking you is do they
still have the power to Scupper a deal
the dup or are they not as powerful as
they used to be well you see and that's
why I'm that's why I'm not going to be
drawn into this because because this is
not this is no because actually the real
giveaway was the subsequent question
about are they not as powerful as they
used to be the dup are passionate
representatives of their communities in
Northern Ireland they foreign
this morning also I was a bit taken
aback by what he was saying about the uh
about secure stama who they want on side
to get this deal through yes interesting
that when you asked whether it was a
compromise he said that the leader of
the opposition didn't understand how
negotiating worked which is well strange
partly because I think many would say
that's exactly how negotiating Works in
talking to sources in government they
think that the that Russia CNAC has
pulled off a very good negotiation he
got a better outcome than many in his
party had expected the criticism
yesterday was very muted from brexiteers
and indeed from dep MPS when he came to
present it to the House of Commons they
were very pleased with that but there
have been compromises of course he's
agreed to drop the protocol bill this
was the attempt by the government to try
and just override bits of the protocol
it didn't like as a kind of threat to
the EU that has been dropped of course
the EU has dropped its legal action
against the UK as well but there has
been give and take on both sides and
that um convivial atmosphere with Ursula
Wonderland yesterday is because of the
the response from the UK Side and being
willing to take steps like that in terms
of the reaction yes it got a very warm
reception yesterday and this is being
described as the most important day of
British cnx Premiership because he stood
up to his party he said this is the deal
I've got and largely they have fallen
into line but there will be difficult
days ahead he's in Northern Ireland
today we don't know yet who he's meeting
but um suspicions are that he will be
meeting all parties there the dup still
holding uh holding back their judgment
no one in government expects them to
come out and say it's fantastic but
whether it's something they can live
with and Stormont can get back up and
running is going to be the key question
yeah and also um who was responsible for
the king getting out the best China for
Ursula of underline but still not very
clear is it I think I think it looked
like it was number 10. well Buckingham
Palace say that he met us live underline
he meets any visiting dignitary who
wants to meet with the King and James
Cleveland careful to say that the palace
organized his diary to make it possible
but the palace have said that they took
the government's advice in terms of the
king meeting Ursula 1 July and so it
does sound like Downing Street at least
gave the meeting its blessing okay for
now let's see whether they meet the dup
today and what influence they still have
over this government who knows no
where are you off to on your holidays
here perhaps
Spanish island of Majorca looking like
that and there's not a swimsuit inside
because it's been hit by blizzard storms
and a red weather warning the swimming
pools are empty the bars are selling hot
coffee and locals have been warned to
expect a foot of snow in the next few
days my goodness me
uh still to come ready steady whose
birthday is it today he's a TV chef I'm
giving you no more clues that was more
than enough Clues find out after the
break
[Music]
now before the break we were telling you
that it's a happy birthday to one of the
country's very favorite TV chefs
Ainsley Harriet is marking his 65th
birthday today he's most famous for
presenting Ready Steady cook which saw
two teams the red tomatoes where they
know and the green peppers face off in
the kitchen he's since had a very
successful television career and was
awarded an MBE in the 2020 New Year's
honors as a big Arsenal fan he'll be
happy his team sits top of the Premier
League today and also that we've got
David Seaman on the program a little bit
later on
meantime Wiz air has announced it will
suspend flights to the moldovan capital
of chisner over airspace safety where is
the Hungarian low-cost Airline announced
yesterday that flights will stop on the
14th of March its decision follows
growing tensions between Russia and
Moldova with missiles targeting Ukraine
reportedly entering moldovan airspace in
early February
a 10-hour drive from the capital chisner
up to Kiev now Ukraine's president for
Vladimir zielinski has warned that the
situation around the town of bakmut is
becoming increasingly difficult as
Russian forces constantly destroy
everything that can be used to portray
protect Ukrainian positions our
International correspondent to Alex
Rossi reports from Eastern Ukraine
this is the scarred and battered mining
town of volidar
it's held by Ukraine but is being
attacked continuously by Russian forces
[Applause]
we entered with a military escort
as it came under Fire again
the soldiers taking us towards Frontline
positions warn us to space out and not
hang around I need to move fast over
this bit is the constant threat of an
artillery strike
it is a gut churning zigzag across the
Broken Ground
while taking cover there are moments of
quiet
before another shell whistle through the
sky
this place has been absolutely
devastated by the fighting
every apartment block has had the
windows blown out there are shell
craters all around us
and there's still plenty of incoming
fire as well
about 15 000 people lived here until it
was smashed by War only a handful
remained there are no services and they
collect rain water from drain pipes to
survive always staying close to cover
it is
watch interview
perhaps nothing sums up the insanity of
the war more than this the wholesale
destruction of people's lives and
possessions
about two kilometers of enemies stand
about two kilometers the town we're told
is strategically important as Ukrainian
forces can Target Russian supply lines
it's why moscow's forces are desperate
to capture it
foreign
ERS has just coordinated a
counter-attack
he shows us a panorama of the town
and the body of a dead Russian Commando
on a live stream beamed from a drone
do you know
uh
foreign
we were taken to another position near
the town this time with a different
Brigade a message comes through that
Russian troops are on the move
since the start of the kremlin's new
offensive they've been very active along
the line of contact
the soldiers in the trenches respond
by laying down an arc of Fire
the razor wire in front of them is a
last defense against Russia's human wave
assaults
the trenches in this part of the front
extend for miles and miles now the team
here their job is to spot for any
movement the Russians are only a couple
of kilometers away and they also have a
Russian radio
and they're able to listen in to their
Communications
the soldiers here say they can defend
their positions they are renewed to this
hell
but Russia is a powerful enemy and
doesn't seem to care how many men it
pushes forwards
Alex Rossi Sky News in eastern Ukraine
well joining us now is the former head
of the British army Lord done it sir
good morning to you my Lord I know you
always want to tread Softly on these
matters but if I could ask you a a
general question who's winning this war
well ukrainians are not losing it and
with the support they've had from the
West they will not lose it the question
is can ukrainians win the Russians are
not going to win but can the ukrainians
win and if so when and of course I think
we all recognize and particularly having
listened to recently to president
zielinski that
um until they get all the Weaponry that
they're asking for when metal tanks
self-propelled artillery and the like
um they won't be able to mount a proper
counter-offensive and crack the Russians
so long answer I'm afraid K to a short
question ukrainians will not lose this
the Russians cannot win it what we have
to do is help the ukrainians to win on
the battlefield but we bring other
pieces into this chess game don't we we
bring in China we bring in Belarus we
bring in Iran and we bring in what's
happening in moldovan air space What
impact is that going to have
well these are all wider considerations
as you quite correctly point out
um yes I think the other thing of course
is interesting is the attack on the
Russian spy plane in in Belarus that's
an indication of the lack of support the
lack of universal support that Putin and
Russia has in the region and then of
course it's there is the wider question
of what support more widely in the world
we see many African nations sitting on
the fence we see China making a very
interesting contribution to all this um
giving moral support but until now not
giving physical support as far as we can
determine and India being pretty pretty
wary in its in its relationship and lack
of warm support for Russia so Putin I
think we have to infer is feeling more
and more isolated and undoubtedly under
huge pressure himself
uh yeah but lots of those armies or
military that are hoping to help Ukraine
are also um struggling some might say
even our own defense secretary says that
um our military and our defense budget
has been hollowed out
well well you're right but of course
these are these are related but these
are separate issues
um and it comes to the live issue in
this country about whether Ben Wallace
will be successful in persuading Jeremy
Hunt to give him an uplift in the
defense budget he's making the case for
somewhere between 8 and 13 billion
pounds extra personally I think that
case is very strong uh and in a sense as
the next former Army Chief I would say
this again that's a part of that
additional money if he's able to get it
must go to our land forces not just to
increase our own capability but to make
up very rapidly for the arms and
Munitions that we have given to the
ukrainians we are being too slow I think
to let contracts to Industry to
replenish our stocks and continue to
make such stocks available to the
ukrainians it's one thing saying that we
support them it's another thing to make
sure they don't lose but we absolutely
have to take the opportunity of giving
them the opportunity to mount a
counter-offensive in the late spring
early summer so that they can win this
war and defeat the Russians on the
battlefield that must be must be the
objective
yeah let's throw another country into
the mix should we Saudi Arabia our
president zielinski met with the Saudi
foreign minister recently
um how do they fit into the mix
well they are an important third party
country as far as all this is concerned
um I mean I think
we would like to expect that Saudi
Arabia will want to support Ukraine I
think Saudi Arabia would probably see
that in the round its best interests are
to support the west and there's a
developing relationship between Saudi
Arabia and America it's kind of complex
relationship up to now but I think the
Saudi rulers are probably coming to the
conclusion that taking everything in the
round it's better to side with Ukraine
supported by the West than to hedge its
best Hedges bets was Russia
okay unfortunately we are out of time
but fascinating stuff as always my Lord
thank you for joining us on the program
this morning thank you thanks Kate thank
you
still to come in the next hour of the
program talking about two big stories
one that has developed uh overnight the
couple missing with their one month old
baby they have been found and arrested
in Brighton where's the baby in addition
to that Northern Ireland the Prime
Minister thinks he's got a deal the dup
said hold your horses he said hang on
I'll get my coat I'm on my way to
Northern Ireland meeting them today what
might come of that stay tuned and find
out more
foreign